I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense there's a ceiling where people
said that was impossible mm-hmm and all
of a sudden human beings are doing it so
no yeah isn't there some story about it
with a four-minute mile like once one
person broke it then the next year 20
did no literally I was later someone
there you go and then there's 1400
people out of broken there doctors were
saying it was impossible explain how
that works like what what happened well
it's an it's in the field you have one
thing happening there's a footprint that
somebody stepped into unconsciousness
that says oh my god someone else did it
I can do it at the same time you're
seeing the evidence in three-dimensional
reality there's a footprint in
consciousness that the person can step
into it's in it's in the field now so at
the same things happening in our work
what was taking three years to happen 10
years ago or eight years ago in one week
we're seeing people heal from the most
incredible health conditions and in
order for that to happen it's not some
miracle it is a change in gene
expression and that's exactly what got
me into measuring all this stuff in the
first place you see someone sitting in a
wheelchair for 10 years with MS at the
end of a weekend workshop she's walking
around the front of the room and hadn't
been out of that throne for 10 years you
start thinking that that's just not
nothing something happened there she
down regulated the gene for MS and she
up regulated the gene for health and she
was taken yoga in a week and she never
done that before so I don't know the
timing because you don't know the
individual case mm-hmm by the same means
you could have someone doing the work
for six months to a weekend event
they're practicing they're ready
everything lines up and they have their
moment and their eczema goes away or
their health condition changes
dramatically and you know that there was
a change in gene expression in that
moment so do you believe that we create
the disease in our body with disease do
we do believe that we create it are we
accountable I do I have to be very
careful about this yeah I understand a
little prep that's probably like you
can't probably want to box yourself into
something but
music I just think that it's really
powerful if that's true because then
you're accountable and that reality is
so much different than well but you know
and then my dad had this and then you
know it's powerful nobody held
accountable then yeah
so the answer is yes and I want to say
yes because I've witnessed so many
incredible things in the last 15 years
here I mean really incredible things
stroke patients that were blind stroke
patients that were paralyzed you know
moving their limbs again getting out of
wheelchairs I mean so so I see that they
can change it because I think many
people when they realize that they
contributed to their health condition
yeah then they understand that that on
some level they created it yeah then
they could uncreate it yes the cool part
yeah that was a practical simple choice
that the person makes right but then you
know the reason I hesitate is because
there's exceptions to every rule I mean
I have my best friend's mother smoked
cigarettes and you know drank whiskey
and was just one of those mothers it was
crazy and we loved her but she lived
like 90 something years old and you know
well you have other people that are you
know vegetarians you know running a 10k
every day doing the right things and you
know they make it yeah that's like you
said the difference between emotion
right course you know maybe you know
your favorite friends mom who was living
it up she didn't have any belief in the
world that she was gonna be sick from it
exam and then the person that's a
vegetarian and concerned about her
health all the time and afraid of
getting sick guts you got it you got it
you got it yeah absolutely that's the
truth and you once you know you can't
not know those people who don't know you
can't unknown agreed so so people that
don't know yeah then don't understand
like that there's some how you say to a
person hey why are you so upset today
why are you so angry today why are you
so frustrated why in a bad mood today
and they'll say oh I was at this place
with this person or these people and
these things happen to me and now I'm
feeling this way and I'm thinking this
way what they're really saying is that
person or that situation was actually
controlling the way
they were feeling and thinking so when
things go well in people's lives they
say hey I'm in a good mood
when things aren't going well in their
life they say they're in a bad mood so
they're victims to the environment all
right so now your thoughts and feelings
actually produce an effect in your
environment and when you begin to
realize that when you change how you
think and feel you change your state of
being when you change your energy you'll
see a change in your life now you got to
be able to sustain that you can't have a
great meditation and do something inward
and then get up in five minutes go
unconscious again you're taking that and
you have to bring it into your life and
be able to sustain it so then the person
who's responding consciously or
unconsciously to the conditions in their
life they don't know they're being a
victim to their life they're saying oh I
have this health condition or this is my
life until you start figuring it out
until you start knowing so knowledge
then becomes the forerunner to
experience so every time you learn
something new you make lots of
connections in your brain not a little a
lot an hour of concentration you'll
double double the number of connections
in your brain from from 1300 to 2,600
but if you don't I think up a lot hours
are concentrated in my life so yeah I'm
pretty excited about that yeah and look
the same so let me finish that thought I
want to respond to that so then you're
laying down philosophical circuits in
your brain the more you think about it
the more you fire and why are those
circuits the repetition of thinking
about it yeah begins to install the
neurological hardware in your brain in
preparation for an experience so the
more you understand what you're doing
and why you're doing it then the how
gets easier so I now know after all the
research you give people to write
scientific information and science is
the contemporary language of mysticism
and they can turn to the person next to
them and explain it because that's what
you'll do I'll say now explain that if
you can't explain it it's not wired in
your brain
[Music]